this was the craziest story
outrageous devastating insane Randall
Emmett is sketch at best
Hollywood movie producer Lola Kent
reality star Vanderpump Rules
Levi style the rolls royces the Jets he
paid so much just to have status
Vanderpump Rules it's about these young
hot 20-somethings this is the juiciest
time in reality show history
how could I not have been smarter like I
beat myself up daily
how is my daughter having to pay for my
stupidity and me keeping my blinders on
and not wanting to see red flags who was
Randa Lambert reeling
Randall was publicly out of apex of his
career he worked with Bruce Willis
Martin Scorsese 50 Cent but really
behind the scenes things were already
starting to fall apart 50 Cent suddenly
goes on Instagram and says Randall you
owe me one million dollars then 50 Cent
posts money by Monday Randall
he made a fateful decision to go on
camera on Vanderpump Rules I literally
would not know the name Randall Emmett
if I didn't see him on Vanderpump rolls
the lawsuits over 30 lawsuits it was
awful to everyone it just came off as
someone who was extremely self-absorbed
I was a personal assistant for Randall
Emmett and executive assistant I was
Randall's assistant for almost a year my
first interaction with Randall was him
in his underwear a bag of cocaine
totally naked the n-word being used is
where I draw the line This is certainly
the underbelly of Hollywood it's not the
part that you see on the postcards
Randall and lot like relationship
started to fall apart
to have your daughter living her life
that way made me feel very sad I hate
random
founding that he's somewhere still
playing victim when what he has actually
done is damage and hurt other people I
have to put up a big fight
I do hope he gets what he deserves the
Rando Scandal love loathing and
Vanderpump
only on Hulu
thank you
[Music]